STATE WE MUST ENSURE THAT
PROGRESS CONTINUES REGARDLESS OF
THE MINISTRATION.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
SPECIFY A PERIOD OF TIME THAT
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
MUST PROVIDE VOTER REGISTRATION
FORMS TO EDUCATIONAL AND
INSTITUTIONS.
SB FOUR THIRTY ONE GUARANTEES IT
THERE IS A PRO ACTIVE PROCESS
FOR ALL HIGH SCHOOLS AND COLLEGE
STUDENTS REQUIRE VOTER
REGISTRATION FORMS BY REQUIRING
THAT THESE FORMS BE SENT WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF A REQUEST BY
SCHOOL -- IN AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
COMMITTEE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I DON'T MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU CENTER OF WHAT IS IN
SUPPORT. TO ME MARK ON THE HALF
OF SECRETARY STATE ALEX PADILLA --
FOR THE REASONS STATED WE
SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
OTHER WITNESSES OTHER OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION ALL
RIGHT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS CENTER LEYVA MOVES
THE BILL -- MOUNTAINS WHICH LIKE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I
DON'T THINK SO MUCH RESEARCH
HERE.
THANK YOU SEVEN REQUIRE OF THEM
SIR TO IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
ALL RIGHT SIR WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT -- SENATOR BATES.
SB
.
FOUR OH ONE CENTER BATES PLEASE
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SB FOUR OH ONE WOULD CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS CANDIDATES
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS TO PROMOTE
THEMSELVES THROUGH THE USE OF
CANDIDATE.
CONTROL BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES WITHOUT BEING SUBJECT
TO OTHERWISE APPLICABLES
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS EXISTING LAW
IMPOSES CANDIDATE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
OF FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED FOR
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY SEVENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED FOR ALL STATEWIDE
OFFICES OTHER THAN GOVERNOR AND
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND FOR THE
GUBERNATORIAL CAMPAIGNS.
THE PARAMETERS ARE INTENDED TO
LIMIT THE DISPROPORTIONATE
INFLUENCE OF WEALTHY DONORS AND
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS ENSURING
CALIFORNIAN.
MOTORS CAN PARTICIPATE.
THE THIS SEEMS TO BE A MUSICAL
ACCOMPANIMENT -- OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WHAT?
HI I'M I APOLOGIZE WE OWE THEM.
TURN DOWN THE MUSIC HOLD SO I'M
NOT EVEN HEARING IT YOU GUYS.
I'M SORRY SENATE PLEASE GO AHEAD --
LET'S SEE I WAS THAT CANDIDATE
CONTROL BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEESON THE OTHER HAND ARE
NOT SUBJECT.
AND TO ANY CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THESE
COMMITTEES ARE OFTEN TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY OR EVEN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN SOME IS GONE AS HIGH
AS A MILLION DOLLARS.
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR ALLOWING
UNLIMITED CONTRIBUTIONS TO THESE
BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEES IS
THAT THEY ARE FORMED WITH THE
LEGAL INTENT TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE BALLOT MEASURES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN CANDIDATE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS WHICH ARE CAPPED
AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO CANDIDATES
CONTROLLED BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES WHICH ARE NOT CAPPED
HAS BEEN HAS BECOME ARE SOMEWHAT
DISTORTED.
SOME CANDIDATES AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS NEW USE THEIR SIZEABLE
BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEES
ACCOUNTS FOR PURPOSES VIRTUALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM
TRADITIONAL CAMPAIGNING.
THE PRACTICE OF USING KENNEDY
CONTROL BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEE
FUNDS FOR KENNEDY CAMPAIGN
PURPOSES DIRECTLY CONTRADICTS
THE WILL OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
WHO OVERWHELMINGLY VOTED TO
ENACT.
THE CONTRIBUTION LIMITS WITH THE
PASSAGE OF PROP.
THIRTY FOUR IT IS CLEAR THAT
CREATIVE SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS.
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE USING
COMMITTEES ARE SOMETIMES TO
CIRCUMVENT THE CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS ENACTED BY PROP.
THIRTY FOUR ACCORDING TO A
REPORT BY THE F. PPC FOLLOWING
THE PROPOSITIONS ENACTMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO KENNEDY
CONTROLLED BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES ROSE BY AN ASTOUNDING.
2100000% DURING THE
INVESTIGATION THE LEAD TO FORMER
SENATOR LELAND HE'S FEDERAL
INDICTMENT.
HE TOLD AN UNDERCOVER F. BY F.
B. I. AGENT HE COULD AVOID THE
RESTRICTIONS OF CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS BY GIVING MONEY TO A
BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEE.
THAT WOULD RAN ADS FEATURING HIM
IN A POSITIVE LIGHT THIS EXAMPLE
SHOWS JUST HOW EASILY THE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS CAN
BE SKIRTED CURRENTLY.
IT IS TIME TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES SO THAT KENNEDY IS AN
ELECTED OFFICIALS CANNOT USE
MANY INTENDED FOR PROMOTING OR
OPPOSING BALLOT MEASURES. TO
INSTEAD PROMOTE THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CAMPAIGNS.
NOW WITH ME TODAY.
FROM THE CLEAN MANY CAMPAIGN IS
TRANSLATING WHO WILL ANSWER ANY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS AND MAKE SOME
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SIR BATES.
SELECT THE THANK YOU -- A GOOD
MORNING CHAIR SENATORS -- I'D
LIKE TO THINK AND CENTER BATES
FOR BRING FORTH THIS IMPORTANT
BILL -- IT DOES GIVE I THINK THE
PUBLIC.
CONCERN ABOUT -- IS AT LEAST THE
APPEARANCES OF OF UNDUE
INFLUENCE FROM SPECIAL INTERESTS
WHEN THEY'RE ABLE TO GIVE THESE
UNLIMITED CONTRIBUTIONS -- TO
CAM A CONTROLLED BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES -- I THINK THE THE A
FORK FOR A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
REASONS AS AS SHE DESCRIBED --
THE THE F. P. B. C. ITSELF BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE BAY
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY TRIED TO PUT
REGULATIONS IN PLACE TO TO TO DO
SO -- AS YOU SEEN THE ANNOUNCES
THE THE COURT AT THE TIME FOUND
THAT THE FPC DID NOT HAVE THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY. TO DO SO --
BUT THEY DID NOT RULE THE COURT
DID NOT RULE ON THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ASPECTS OF OF
THERE BEING A WOMEN SO THERE IS
A BIG DIFFERENCE HERE THIS ISN'T
THIS BILLS NOT TRYING TO SAY YOU
CAN'T HAVE HAVE.
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS TO ANY ABOUT
MEASURE COMMITTEE JUST A
CANDIDATE CONTROLLED BALLOT
MEASURE COMMITTEES -- AS A P. B.
C. IN -- TWO THOUSAND FIVE
RECOMMENDED DOING SO SO WE WOULD
STRONGLY AGREEWITH THIS BILL
AND AND HOPED URGE THAT YOU --
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS AT THE SETTLERS
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THE REASON UNDER US SUPREME
COURT JURISPRUDENCE WELL YOU
CAN'T HAVE CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
ON THAT MEASURE CAMPAIGNS IS
THAT THEY CAN'T HAVE OSTENSIBLY
CORRUPTING INFLUENCE ON
CANDIDATES.
WE THINK -- WHEN YOU HAVE CAN BE
CONTROLLED BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES OF THAT IS A
DIFFERENT PIECE THAT IS A
DISTINCTION THAT'S WORTH NOTING?
SO FOR EXAMPLE UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE PERSON COULD GIVE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO CANDY
CONTROL BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEE
AND I CAN THEY COULD THEN TURN
AROUND AND FUTURE ADDS.
OSTENSIBLY FOR THE BALLOT
MEASURE BUT ALSO PAIN THEMSELVES
IN A POSITIVE LIGHT THIS SEEMS
TO BE A A WAY TO CIRCUMVENT A
POSSIBILITY CIRCUMVENTING OR
EXISTING CAMPAIGN FINANCE RULES --
WE THINK WITH THIS BILL SIMPLY
DANCES STATUS IS A CLEAR BRIGHT
LINE RULE FOR THE SAME
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS THAT APPLY
TO CAN IT'S ALSO APPLY TO CAN TO
CONTROL BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES.
I THINK IT'S A VERY ELEGANT AND
SIMPLE WAY OF ENSURING THAT
MONEY DOESN'T.
USUALLY CIRCUMVENT OUR EXISTING
RULES FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OTHERS OTHERS IS FOR OPPOSITION.
SANDERS PHILIP í
OF THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION ARE BIPARTISAN
COMMISSION VOTED UNANIMOUSLY IN
MARCH -- TO OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR
THE REASONS STATED IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT NOW
FOR THE WITNESSES WILL BRING
BACK COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
YES SIR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HOW OFTEN
DOES THAT HAPPEN I KNOW YOU --
STATED THAT -- LELAND HE MADE
THE COMMENT I GUESS TO THE FBI
OR WHATNOT BUT YOU KNOW I'VE
KNOWN A NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT
HAVE CANDIDATE COMMITTEES I
DON'T HAVE ONE MYSELF.
BUT I HAVE NOT KNOWN THEM TO USE
IT FOR THE PURPOSES THAT YOU'RE
STATING SO HOW OFTEN DOES IT
ACTUALLY HAPPEN I DON'T HAVE ANY
PERCENTAGE BUT I KNOW THE
MERCURY NEWS ARTICLE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN MENTIONED.
THAT NEARLY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS SPENT BY THESE
COMMITTEES SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
ONLY ONE DOLLAR OUT OF EVERY
FOUR WAS USED TO HELP.
PASS OR KILL MEASURES THE
BALANCE WAS MANAGED BY THE
CANDIDATE -- TOO YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY PROMOTE THEMSELVES.
PAYMENTS ON THEIR VARIETY OF
WAYS AND I KNOW WHAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE SEEN IT USED A LOT.
ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN CITIES
ELECTIONS.
IN SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY.
I WONDER IF MAYBE IT'S MORE OF A
LOCAL ISSUE THAT I I'M THE YOU
KNOW WE ALL TEND TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE DO RIGHT I'M THINKING OF
OTHER SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY
FOLKS SO ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THERE NIELSEN DUMP.
LET ME ASK A QUESTION. FOUR NINE
KENNEDY CONTROLLED BALLOT
MEASURE COMMITTEES IS THERE A
PROHIBITION ON THE SUPPORTERS
FEATURING A PARTICULAR ELECTED
OFFICIAL.
SLANG DO NOT ABOUT NOT THAT I AM
AWARE OF THERE ARE THERE LIMITS
THAT THEIR PPVS PUT INTO PLACE --
LIMITS THAT WHEN A ABOUT MAJOR
COMMITTEE DOES FEATURE CANADA AT
THE BEHEST OF THE CANDIDATE THAT
THEN.
THE CONTRIBUTION LIMITS START TO
KICK IN AFTERWARDS -- BUT THAT'S
THE ONLY ONE THAT I'M AWARE OF
RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE US SENATOR
ON UNDER YOU WOULD HAVE TO
REPORTED AS AN IN KIND
CONTRIBUTION. TO YOUR CAMPAIGN
AND WILL YOU KNOW WE'RE LIMITED
ON OUT SO.
THAT'S PROBABLY HOUSE CONTROL
MAYBE INDIRECTLY.
I WOULD ASSUME BECAUSE IT'S AN
IN KIND CONTRIBUTION WHEN
THEY'RE PROMOTING YOU.
RIGHT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE LET'S SAY COMMON
CAUSE FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD A
BALLOT MEASURE AND THEY FEATURED
A PARTICULAR ELECTED OFFICIAL
WHATEVER.
AMOUNT OF FOR EXAMPLE TELEVISION
ADVERTISING THAT WOULD ALL BE AN
IN KIND CONTRIBUTION.
I THINK THEY WOULD HAVE TO
REPORT THAT I AM NOT THE MVPS.
DECIDER ON THAT BALLOT MY GUESS
IS IF IT WAS SUBMITTED TO THEM
OUT SO.
YOU KNOW.
NOT REPORTED ON MY FORM THAT I
WAS PROMOTED WITH -- LET'S SAY A
STATEWIDE BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEE THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY
I THINK THAT WOULD BE A PROBLEM
IF.
IT IF IT WAS DONE WITH LET'S SEE
AN INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURE
COMMITTEE AND I HAD NO
CONNECTION OR MY CONSULTANTS.
THINK IT WOULD HAVE TO BE A
TOTAL REVIEW OF WHAT MY
INVOLVEMENT IN THAT WAS.
LOOKING AT ME THAT WOULD LIKELY
HAVE OF A PHONE A FRIEND HERE SO
YES -- THE PPC.
HI SENATOR -- SO THAT YOU MIGHT
MY QUESTION BY POLITICAL
QUESTION YEAH -- IN YOUR
HYPOTHETICAL IF -- THE IN OR
EVER COMMITTEE HAD FEATURED A A
CANDIDATE OR AN ELECTED OFFICIAL --
IN AN ADVERTISEMENT -- AND OF
COURSE THE CONTEXT DEPENDS ON
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S EXPRESS
ADVOCACY WHEN IT TALKS ABOUT
THAT OFFICIAL IF IT'S SIMPLY
JUST FEATURES THE OFFICIAL.
AND THE OFFICIAL -- APPROVES THE
FEATURING OF THAT OF THEIR IMAGE --
OUR CURRENT REGULATIONS WOULD
TRIGGER -- A CONTRIBUTION LIMIT
OF THE POLITICAL PARTIES -- IF
THAT FEATURING AT THE BEHEST THE
CANADA OCCURRED IN THE LAST
FORTY FIVE DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
AND THAT IS OUR DEREGULATION IS
AN APPLICATION OF A STATUTE THAT
WAS ADOPTED BY THE VOTERS AND
PROPOSITION.
THIRTY FOUR OKAY AND WHAT IF FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THE A COMMITTEE
FORMED IN OPPOSITION TO A A
BALLOT MEASURE CANDIDATE CONTROL
COMMITTEE FORMED IN OPPOSITION
TO A BALLOT MEASURES THAT.
WITH THIS.
LAW PERTAIN TO THAT SITUATION AS
WELL.
I'M NOT SURE AND YOU MAY KNOW
LOVE THE WORDS LET'S SAY.
COMMON CAUSE HAS AN INITIATIVE
THAT THE BALLOT MEASURE.
AND THEN THERE'S A CANDIDATE
CONTROLLED COMMITTEE THE THEN
FORMS TO OPPOSE THAT BALLOT
MEASURE WITH THE RESTRICTIONS BE
IN PLACE FOR THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL AS THE PROMOTION NO.
NO.
IT WOULD JUST BE FOR THE
CANDIDATE CONTROLLED COMMITTEE
AND I WOULD ASSUME THAT THE OF
COMMON CAUSE HE IS PROMOTING
SOMETHING.
AND I'M THE CANDIDATE AND I AM A
BALLOT MEASURE. TO I HAVE A
MEASURE TO THE POLLS THAT I
WOULD BE AONGST PROBABLY OTHERS
WHO ARE OPPOSING IT ALSO.
HI WOULD BE LIMITED TO THE FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS AS A
SENATOR.
DO YOU SEE ANY.
OF THE CONTRIBUTION TO ME FOR
THAT PURPOSE.
THE END DO YOU SEE ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL INFIRMITY SAVE
ANY LEGAL INFIRMITIES. TO THIS
MEASURE.
I'LL ASK YOU THE PPC HERE MISTER
LINE -- WE IT'S IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE RAISES
THAT BBC REYES DIDN'T BUT THE
THE THE CLEARLY.
LIMITS ON ON CONDITIONS
CANDIDATES ARE ARE QUITE
CONSTITUTIONAL THIS IS A MATTER
OF INTERPRETATION IF IT'S
pWOULD BELIEVE THAT THAT THIS
WOULD BE CONSTITUTIONAL THE FTC
HAS A DIFFERENT -- THE BASIS OF
OUR OPPOSITION IS BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION FOR BELIEVES THIS
PROPOSAL IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL --
BASED ON THE CURRENT --
PRESIDENT -- ESTABLISH AND RENT
CONTROL -- IN THE RENT CONTROL
CASE -- IT IS A CANDY CONTROL
BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEE BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BALANCE OF
THESE ACTIVITIES IT IS MORE
BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTED IS
CANADA COMMITTEE.
SO I THINK THAT'S HOW WE CAME TO
THAT POSITION OF OPPOSITION ZIP
PPC EVER.
ASIDE THAT A CANDIDATE CONTROL
BALLOT MEASURE COMMITTEE
ACTUALLY BECOMES BASICALLY THE
COMMITTEE. FOR THE PURPOSE.
EXCLUSIVELY OR PREDOMINANTLY TO
SUPPORT A CANDIDATE -- LAND
THEREFORE BASICALLY REVOKE ITS I
SUPPOSE STATUS IS A IS A ABOUT
MEASURE COMMITTEE -- I CAN'T
THINK OF A CASE BUT IF THAT WAS
TO OCCUR -- THERE WOULD BE -- A
NUMBER OF ISSUES FOR THAT
COMMITTEE -- BECAUSE THAT
COMMITTEE WOULD THEN -- SAVE A
CANDIDATE HAD A CHARACTER BALLOT
MEASURE COMMITTEE AND THEY USE
THE MONEY THAT WAS COLLECTED
ABOVE THE LIMITS.
AND THEN THE USE THAT MONEY TO
PROMOTE THEMSELVES FOR THEIR
REELECTION USING EXPRESS
ADVOCACY -- WE WOULD CONSIDER
THAT A VIOLATION OF THE
EXPENDITURE RULES THAT WE HAVE
ON CAN'T GET TO A BALLOT MEASURE
COMMITTEES -- WE WOULD CONSIDER
THAT AN ELECTION COMMITTEE --
AND THEN WE WOULD ESSENTIALLY --
WE MAY LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE NOT
SUBJECT TO LIMIT NOW SUBJECT TO
WOMEN AND LOOK AT THE SPENDING.
OF THAT COMMITTEE -- AND NOT TO
MENTION IF -- THE THE CANDIDATE
ALREADY HAD AN ELECTION
COMMITTEE THAN THEY WOULD
VIOLATE ONE TAKE ACCOUNT ROLE ON
BECAUSE THEY WERE SUCH THAT TO
CANADA COMMITTEES.
OKAY THE CENTER BATES THE AT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
AND I'M NOT PREPARED TODAY TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I BUT I AM
PREPARED TO WORK WITH YOU
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE DOES DESERVE
SOME SCRUTINY -- BUT I THINK
THERE'S A NUMBER OF FEDERAL LAWS
THAT THE BUT SHOULD BE CHANGED --
THE US SUPREME COURT AND THE
NEXT SESSION OR SESSIONS
THEREAFTER WILL DO SO BUT I'M
NOT PREPARED RIGHT NOW IS TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I'M HERE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YES SIR LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
WOULD JUST SAY I FEEL THE SAME
WAY I THINK THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT I THINK IT
NEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK.
SO I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HELP AS
WELL MISTER CHAIR IF THERE'S
ANYTHING I CAN DO BUT I DO THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT AND I DO
THINK WE SHOULD PROBABLY TRY
SOME OTHER AVENUE TO TO GET IT
TO WHERE WE ALL FEEL COMFORTABLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT OUT OF THE OFFICE ARE.
NON SUPPORTED -- ALL RIGHT OF SO
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION MADE --
MAP SECTOR IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ON BURKE ALL
NUMBERED NO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA.
LEYVA NO STERN.
SO CENTER WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU -- THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTARY AND I CERTAINLY THINK
WE ALL RECOGNIZE THERE'S A
LOOPHOLE IS THIS THE FIX FOR IT.
I THINK I'M HEARING WE'RE NT
THERE YET THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTARY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR -- NEXT -- CENTER
MORLOCK [inaudible]
ABOUT.
THEM THE POINT.
SIR MORE LUCK THE OF FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WAS JUST IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO
ACROSS THE HALL AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT ONE ONE THREE HAS
PIPED IN MUSIC SO THANK.
YES I WAS IS JUST FOR YOU BUT I
I THINK CENTER BATES ALSO WAS
ACCOMPANIED BY MUSIC SO -- YEARS
MUSIC'S BETTER THOUGH I I GOT TO
TELL YOU THAT.
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES A NUMBER
OF RESIDENTS IN NEWPORT BEACH
OPPOSED THE BUILDING OF A
CONDOMINIUM HIGH RISE TOWER THAT
WAS APPROVED.
BY CITY COUNCIL AS APPALLED CITY
CODE PROVISIONS.
IN ORDER TO GATHER THE NECESSARY
SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY A BALLOT
MEASURE THE OPPONENTS WERE
REQUIRED TO ATTACH A COPY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT.
SOME ONE THOUSAND PAGES TO EACH
PETITION DOCUMENT.
THIS WAS VERY CLEVER BUT IT WAS
ALSO VERY EXPENSIVE ALTHOUGH I
MAY NOT HAVE NECESSARILY AGREED
WITH THE OPPOSITION OF ADDING
NEW HOUSING I ALSO DO NOT AGREE
WITH OBSTRUCTIONIST TACTICS TO
DIS INCENTIVIZE CITIZENS.
FROM PARTICIPATING AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
A SUMMARY OF THE E. I. R. SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE THAN ADEQUATE.
SB THREE FIFTY NINE TRIES TO
FIND A COMPROMISE BETWEEN AN
ONEROUS DOCUMENT AND NO PROJECT
DETAILS AT ALL.
I'M ASKING THAT ATTACHING
SPECIFIED DECLARATIONS TO
REFERENDUM PETITIONS WE ARE
RESPONSIBLEIN POSITION AND NOT
A CUMBERSOME OBSTACLE TO
EXERCISE TO THE EXERCISE OF
PARTICIPATING IN GOVERNMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE A KEY WITNESS.
THANK YOU SIR WATER SKINNER YES
YOU.
THIS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS SUSAN
SKINNER AND I'M HERE TO ASK YOU
TO USE YOUR LEGISLATIVE SUPER
POWERS TO WRITE OF SERIOUS ROCK.
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT
SENATOR MORLOCKS SB THREE FIFTY
NINE WHICH WILL PREVENT FUTURE
ABUSES OF THE REFERENDUM PROCESS.
IN NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE NEWPORT BEACH CITY COUNCIL
APPROVED A TWENTY FIVE STORY
CONDOMINIUM TOWER.
KNOWING THAT MY GROUP IS GOING
TO RUN A REFERENDUM TO OVERTURN
THEIR DECISIONS THEY ADDED
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED UNNECESSARY
PAGES TO THE TEXT OF THE
ORDINANCE INCLUDING THE ENTIRETY
I ARE IN THE LAND USE ELEMENT OF
THE GENERAL PLAN.
THEY DID THIS BECAUSE THE COURTS
HAVE HELD THAT ANY DOCUMENTS
ADDED TO AN ORDINANCE MUST BE
INCLUDED IN THE REFERENDUM
PETITION.
CHALLENGES THAT BECAUSE OF THEIR
ACTION WE ENDED UP WITH THIS
PETITION.
DON'T HURT YOURSELF I WANT TO
BEEN DOING THIS A LOT.
THIS IS.
ONE IT HAS ROOM FOR A HUNDRED
SIGNATURES WE NEED EIGHT
THOUSAND IN ORDER TO QUALIFY THE
REFERENDUM.
BECAUSE OF THEIR ACTION -- EACH
PETITIONCOST ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO PRINT AND USE TEN
POUNDS OF PAPER THEY
COLLECTIVELY COST FORTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO PRINT THESE
PETITIONS. TO HAVE THIRTY DAYS
TO GATHER THE NECESSARY
SIGNATURES AND THE PRINTING OF
THESE PETITIONS REQUIRED NINE
DAYS.
THE NEWPORT BEACH CITY COUNCIL
KNEW EXACTLY WHAT THEY WERE
DOING BECAUSE ONE OF THE
COUNCILMEN MADE AN IMPASSIONED
PLEA TO HIS COLLEAGUES NOT TO
MAKE THE REFERENDUM LOOK LIKE A
PHONE BOOK.
WE WERE ULTIMATELY SUCCESSFUL IN
OBTAINING THE SIGNATURES NEEDED
THE BARRIERS PLACED BY OUR CITY
COUNCIL CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED.
AND A LESS WELL ORGANIZED GROUP
THE LOSS OF NINE DAYS TO PRINT
THE PETITIONS WOULD HAVE BEEN
FATAL.
IN A LESS AFFLUENT CITY THE
FORTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR COST
OF THE PETITIONS WERE SHUT DOWN
THE EFFORT IMMEDIATELY.
THE FACT THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
REFERENDUM DOES NOT DIMINISH
DIMINISH THE MALFEASANCE SHOWN
BY THE COUNCIL.
THE FACT THAT THEY COULD USE
THEIR LEGISLATIVE POWERS TO
BLOCK OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
WITH IMPUNITY REQUIRES IN MY
OPINION SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES TO
THE LAW.
I MADE A COMPLAINT TO THE GRAND
JURY AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE BOTH OF WHOM OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION AND BOTH OF WHOM
CONCLUDED THAT IT WAS NOT A
CRIME FOR THE CITY COUNCIL TO
HAVE TAKEN THIS ACTION.
THUS THE ONLY AVENUE OPEN TO
PREVENT FREE FUTURE ABUSES IS
THE LEGISLATIVE PATH.
DEMOCRACY WORKS BEST WHEN
DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES ARE
RESPECTED.
THE RIGHT TO PETITION ONE'S
GOVERNMENT IS AMONG THE MOST
PRECIOUS RIGHTS THAT WE HAVE.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
PROTECT THE DEMOCRATIC BALANCE
OF POWER IN FUTURE REFERENDUMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MS SKINNER --
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY BEEN HANGING
AROND CENTER MORE LIKE TOO MUCH
BECAUSE THE REST OF US DID NOT
HAVE SUPER SUPER HUMAN PWERS SO.
I KNOW YOU DO.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT -- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS THE
QUESTIONS THE QUESTIONS HERE'S A
A COUPLE ISSUES -- ONE THAT I'D
LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON CENTER
MORE LIKE IS KIDS -- MAYBE IT'S
PROTECTING A BROTHER OR SISTER
IN THE BAR IS THE SEVEN DAY
TURNAROUND IS IS VERY VERY QUICK --
SO AT AT AND LIKE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON PERHAPS EXTENDING THAT
SEVEN DAY PERIOD OR DEFINING IT
AS BUSINESS DAYS OR SOMETHING
THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME -- AND IT'S IT
COULD BE QUITE A BIT OF WORK TO
BE ABLE TO PUT THAT TOGETHER.
THE BE LOTS OF INPUT I AM SURE --
AS WE'VE EXPERIENCE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SO ARE YOU A U.
AMENABLE TO TO WORK ON THAT TIME
PERIOD I'LL RESPECT YOUR SUPER
POWERS RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU -- IT ALSO AND JUST
SOME ISSUES WITH WITH THE THE
THE TIMING -- THE SEVEN DAYS
THAT THE THIRTY DAYS THAT KIND
OF THING I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WE HAVE.
PROVIDED SUFFICIENT TIME TO BE
ABLE TO TO DO AN ADEQUATE
ANALYSIS IN SUMMARY SO WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE LEGAL FIGHTS OVER
WHETHER THE PHONE BOOK WOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE APPROPRIATE.
SO IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE
AMENABLE.
TO TO WORK WITH US ON ON THOSE
ISSUES AND THEN I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
I'M I'M I'M AMENABLE AND I GOT A
WORK WITH THE DOCTOR SKINNER AS
WELL MAKE SURE THAT SHE'S.
HAPPY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GOOD
FORM.
BUT THAT'S ALL WE'RE TRYING. TO
TO DO.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU AS OUR
MOTION I WILL DO SO.
SENATE NIELSEN MOVES UP.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SIR OF THE
DRUG CLOSE.
BECAUSE I JUST DID IRAQ WE ASK
YOU AND I BOTH ALL RIGHT.
WELL SIR DID YOU CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER
HI NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN.
THE BILLS OUT THANKS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- YEAH WE WHAT WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SO -- ALL RIGHT --
OTHER AUTHORS WE'RE WE'RE IN
NEED IN SEARCH OF OTHER AUTHORS.
I'M AN AUTHOR ALL RIGHT
[inaudible]
AND TO SO [inaudible]
SINCE THE FOR TWENTY THREE HE
SAID.
ALL RIGHT WE GO TO THE ALRIGHT
LET LET WHEN WE DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- RIGHT -- BUT ANY
QUESTIONS ISSUES CONCERNING
CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING NONE
MA'AM SECTOR TO CALL THE ROLL.
I KNOW FOR CONSENT AS SB SIX
NINETY SIX NUMBER. FIVE NUMBER
GUY NIELSEN FOR THE CONSENT.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG LEYVA.
LIVE AYE AYES STERN [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN ON THE
CONSENT CALDERON THE TURN THE
TABLES AND YOU'LL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WILL YOU BE
BEGIN WITH -- THREE THREE
HUNDRED ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
THE NIELSEN -- SB THREE HUNDRED
IS A VERY SIMPLE BILL IT --
CURRENTLY LAW PROHIBITS FOREIGN
PERSONS AND ORGANIZATIONS FOR
MAKING CONTRIBUTIONS -- OR AN
EXPENDITURES IN CONNECTION WITH
OUR STATE LOCAL BALLOT MEASURE
CAMPAIGNS SB THREE HUNDRED WILL
AMEND THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT
ALSO FOREVER THIS ACTIVITY IN
CONNECTION WITH CALIFORNIA STATE.
AND LOCAL CANDIDATES CAMPAIGNS.
S. REVIVAL.
VERY GOOD.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
DRILLING CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN WE SUPPORT THIS BILL IT
MAKES SENSE TO EXTEND THE FORTY
TO FIFTY BC THANK YOU.
BECAUSE I DON'T WAS CALIFORNIA
COME BECAUSE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
AND THE OTHER SUPPORT.
PRESENT.
GOT.
ANY OPPOSITION [inaudible]
NO OPPOSITION
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE MEMBERS.
BILL THE MOTION. TO PASS.
AND WHAT WE CALL THE ROLL.
BOB I WAS ABLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER
HI I'M BURKE AYE NIELSEN AYE
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
WHAT IS ABOUT THANK YOU?
AND WE'LL PUT ON WE HAVE THE
FOUR TWENTY THREE CENTER ALLEN
IS HERE.
SO WILL IT CENTER ALLEN GO.
THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
I APPRECIATE [inaudible]
YOUR FORBEARANCE -- FOR
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS.
YES I WAS JUST OVER ACROSS THE
HALL AND WITH ONE OF YOUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS CHAIRING
THE NOT TO RESOURCES WANT TO
COMMITTEE SO -- HE'S CLOSE BY IF
YOU NEED FOR VOTE.
I'VE IF YOU IF IF I MAY I'D LOVE
TO PRESENT SB.
TWO TWELVE PLEASE ENCLOSURES
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MINSITER
MEMBERS AT THIS BILL SB.
TWO TWELVE SIMPLY AUTHORIZES
GENERAL LOST CITIES.
GENERAL ON COUNTIES.
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO UTILIZE
TO MAJORITY WINNER VOTING
METHODS FOR LOCAL ELECTIONS SO
ONE OPTION WOULD BE -- AND BY
THE WAY ALL OF THIS IS
PERMISSIVE A TEST IF THE LOCALS
WANT TO DO IT THEY CAN DO IT.
UNDER THIS BILL -- IT'S
BASICALLY AFFORDS A RIGHT THAT
IT CURRENTLY EXISTS FOR CHARTER
CITIES.
I TO THE GENERAL OUT FOLKS IN
THE COULD.
YOU GIVE TO ADDITIONAL OPTIONS
ONE OF THE TWO ROUND RUNOFF.
AND THE OTHER IS RANKED CHOICE
VOTING.
UNDER CURRENT STATE LAW VOTERS
IN GENERAL I CITIES HAVE TO
ELECT THEIR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
USED A VERY PARTICULAR WAY IT'S
A PLURALITY WINNER VOTING SYSTEM --
SO YOU CAN GET.
IN IN A CROWDED FIELD LET'S SAY
THERE'S A SEAT FOR ONE YOU KNOW
OF OF OF THE VOTE FOR ONE SEAT.
YOU CAN GET 20% OF ALL IN YOUR
THE CITY COUNCIL MEMBER -- IF
THERE'S A LOT OF CANDIDATES AND
YOU THE TOP VOTER VOTE GETTER --
CHARTER CITIES HAVE THE
AUTHORITY OF COURSE TO ADOPT
MAJORITY WINNER VOTING METHODS
LIKE A TWO ROUND RUNOFF OR
RANGERS VOTING IF THEY WANT --
TO SO AT THE AT THE CONCERN I
HAVE COMING TO ALL THIS IS HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
LOCALLY ELECTED BODIES THAT
TRULY ENJOY THE MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION THAT.
ARE IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND HERE'S THE SHOCKING STAT --
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE DUE TO
ANALYSIS OF CITY ELECTIONS FROM
201-622-0006.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND
FOUNDED IN RACES WITH THREE OR
MORE CANDIDATES NEARLY HALF OF
THE CITY COUNCIL CANDIDATES WERE
ELECTED.
WITH LESS THAN MAJORITY SUPPORT --
SO ALRIGHT FOLKS KNOW ABOUT THE
PEOPLE SEEM BY THESE TWO
DIFFERENT OPTIONS -- ONE IS THE
THE TWO ROUND.
RUNOFF RIGHT WHAT SO YOU HAVE A
A WIDE OPEN RACE FOR THE PRIMARY
AND THE GENERAL THE TOP TWO VOTE
GETTERS RUNOFF AGAINST EACH
OTHER WE ALL HAD TO GO THROUGH
HER CELLS AND WE RUNNING FOR THE
STATE SENATE.
I SUCH A SIMPLE SYSTEM.
THE OTHER SYSTEM OF COURSE THE
RAIN CHOICE VOTING.
ELECTION MAJORITY WINTER BUT IN
A SINGLE ACTION EACH VOTER HAS
ONE VOTE THE RANK THE CANDIDATES
IN ORDER OF PREFERENCE.
ON AND THE RESULTS ARE TABULATED
ROUNDS IF NO CANDIDATE RECEIVES
A MAJORITY VOTE IN THE FIRST
ROUND AND THIS PROCEEDS UNTIL A
CANDIDATE.
RECEIVES MORE THAN 50% -- BASED
ON PEOPLE SECOND AND THIRD
CHOICE AND SO ON VOTES SO WE
HAVE RANGERS VOTING IN A NUMBER
CITIES AFTER MUNICIPAL ELECTION
SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND BERKELEY
SANLEANDRO.
IT CETERA -- AND ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS GIVES THE GENERAL US
CITIES THE RIGHT TO DO WHAT THE
CHARTER CITIES HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO NOW SO DOZEN IMPOSES UPON
THEM.
IT JUST SAYS THEY CAN USE THIS
AS AN OPTION IF THEY SO CHOOSE --
IN THE FUTURE AND THAT'S UP TO
THEM LOCALLY.
SO MY THOUGHT IS IS THAT -- BY
GIVING THEM THIS THESE
ADDITIONAL TOOLS -- THAT YOU'LL
GIVE THEM THE TOOLS THEY CAN
UTILIZE TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
ELECTED OFFICIALS ACTUALLY
ENJOYS SUPPRT FROM.
A MAJORITY OF THEIR A LECTOR
PART OF THE DEAL HERE COURSES
AND AND THE CITY THE COMMITTEE
WAS VERY.
YOU KNOW PASSION ABOUT THIS IF
THEY THE JURISDICTION IS TO
CHOOSE TO A DOCTOR ENTERS VOTING
BEHALF TO ADOPT A COMPREHENSIVE
VOTER EDUCATION PLAN THEY HAV.
TO HAVE -- VOTER EDUCATION FOR
TWO GENERAL ELECTION SO THERE'S
A SLOW ROLLOUT TO THIS ANY WOULD
REALLY INVOLVES MAKING SURE
PEOPLE ARE PROPERLY INFORMED.
SO THAT -- THAT YOU KNOW THEY
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
THEMSELVES INTO BUT WITH THIS
AND WITH THIS I HAVE HERE TO
TESTIFY -- ON SUPPORT SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PEDRO HERNANDEZ FROM
VERBAL CALIFORNIA ALSO CARE
BRINSON.
FROM THE RIGHT CHOICE VOTING
RESOURCE CENTER AND I RESPECT
YESTERDAY WILL.
GREAT -- MY NAME IS BETTER KNOWN
AS ON THE SENIOR POLICY
COORDINATOR AT FAIR BUT
CALIFORNIA -- THERE WILL
CALIFORNIA BELIEVES THAT A
HEALTHY LONG LASTING DEMOCRACY
RELIES ON EVERY CITIZEN HAVING A
RIGHTS TO VOTE THAT CAN TRULY
CONTRIBUTE TO MEANINGFUL
REPRESENTATION -- AS CURLEY'S
CURRENTLY GENERAL ON CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND ONLY HOLD PLURALITY WINNER
ELECTIONS.
IN WHICH THE CANDOR WITH THE
MOST VOTES WINS -- EVEN IF THE
MAJORITY DID NOT VOTE FOR THAT
CANDIDATE WE'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
IN CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED -- THE
COMMON CAUSE REPORT DID SHOW
THAT 42% OF SINGLE ELECTIONS
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SIX IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WERE ELECTED
WITH LESS THAN A MAJORITY OF
VOTES -- THIS CAN REALLY.
UNDERMINE VOTER CONFIDENCE IN
ELECTIONS IN GOVERNMENT AND
FEDERAL BELIEVES THAT CALIFORNIA
RESTRICTIONS SHOULD NOT BE
PRECLUDED FROM ADOPTING VOTING
SYSTEMS THAT ALLOW FOR A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OUTCOMES -- THE
CURRENT LAW CHARTER CITIES AND
COUNTIES MAY USE RUNOFF
ELECTIONS ANDRANGE WAS VOTING
THIS MEANS ROUGHLY 75% OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND COUNTIES
DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO USE
THESE METHODS.
THAT ARE LOST CITIES IN ORDER TO
GET TO THAT WOULD NEED TO PASS A
CHARTER AMENDMENT WHICH COULD
MEAN A YEAR OR TWO DOWN THE LINE
IN WHICH THEY CAN ACTUALLY LOOK
AT THAT OPTION.
AND THAT COMES WITH OTHER
COMPLICATED ISSUES -- SO THIS IS
ENTIRELY PERMISSIVE BILL TO
ALLOW THESE CITIES THAT HAPPEN
OPTION TO AND LIKE THE
REPRESENTED BY MAJORITY.
ON THIS BILL IS NECESSARY ENSURE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO ADOPT AN ELECTION
AT THE BUT STREETS THEIR LOCAL
NEEDS -- MILLIE TO DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS THAT WORKS BETTER FOR
EVERYONE -- WE'VE SEEN RANGE WAS
VOTING RESULT IN HIGHER PARTED
TO PARTICIPATION RATES.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TURNOUT
IN ALL JURISDICTIONS HOLDING
RANCHERS BUT ELECTIONS TO PASS
PROJECTIONS FAVORITE CISCO HAD
MORE VOTERS IN THE RAIN CHOICE
VOTING CONTESTS FOR MAYOR.
THEN VOTER FOR GOVERNOR AND
SENTE.
WHICH WERE NOT RANGE WAS PUTTING
CONTESTS -- IT WAS THE SECOND
HIGHEST VOTE TOTAL IN SAN
FRANCISCO MERYL HISTORY.
EXIT POLLS OF SIXERS SECTIONS
THAT USE RANGE WAS VOTING FOR ON
AVERAGE 84% OF VOTERS REPORT
THAT THEY UNDERSTOOD THE SYSTEM
EXTREMELY VERY OR SOMEWHAT WELL --
IN ADDITION SB TWO ONE TWO
REQUIRES YOUR SUCCESS EDUCATE
VOTERS ABOUT RANGE WAS VOTING TO
MAKE SURE.
VOTERS ARE AWARE OF THE CHANGE
THAT FOR THE FIRST TWO ELECTIONS --
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFYING FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
I'VE.
WE AYE ARJA AND NAY VOTE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME ALL THE WAY
FROM CHARLESTON SOUTH CAROLINA --
MY NAME IS KAREN BRINSON BELL
AND I'VE CONDUCTED ELECTIONS.
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE INCLUDING
CITY AND DISTRICT INSTANT RUNOFF
ELECTIONS AND I WAS PART.
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION TEAM FOR
STATE WIDE USE OF RIGHT CHOICE
VOTING IN A NORTH CAROLINA
ELECTION FOR THE COURT OF
APPEALS SEAT THAT BECAME VACANT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN THAT WAS
ACTUALLY THE FIRST STATEWIDE USE
OF OUR CV.
IN THE UNITED STATES SINCE THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES AND WE
IMPLEMENTED IN JUST EIGHTY SIX
DAYS -- I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE RIGHT CHOICE VOTING RESOURCE
CENTER WERE NON ADVOCACY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WE'RE
FOCUSED ON EDUCATION AND JUST
THE SHARING OF BEST PRACTICES IN
ELECTION MINISTRATION
PARTICULARLY FOR RIGHT CHOICE
VOTING.
CURRENTLY RCV WE'VE TOUCHED ON
THIS BUT IT IS USED IN A LEVIN
US CITIES INCLUDING MINNEAPOLIS
MINNESOTA SAN FRANCISCO.
SANTA FE NEW MEXICO WAS THE MOST
RECENT.
CAMBRIDGE MASSACHUSETTS HAS
ACTUALLY USE THE MULTI WINNER
FORMER RIGHT CHOICE VOTING FOR
MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE YEARS.
OZ SO IT'S PROVEN IT'S NOT A NEW
CONCEPT.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
STATE OF MAINE USED RCV OR ITS
STATE AND FEDERAL PRIMARIES.
AND THEN FOR ITS US HOUSE AND
SENATE GENERAL ELECTION.
FOURTEEN ADDITIONAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
APPROVED RIGHT CHOICE VOTING FOR
FUTURE ELECTIONS.
BOB THIS IMPLEMENTATION
ADMINISTRATION PRACTICES TO DRAW
FROM THAT MAY BE HELPFUL IN YOUR
DECISION MAKING.
RIGHT CHOICE VOTING ELECTIONS
REALLY ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN ANY
OTHER ELECTION.
IMPLEMENTATION A RIGHT CHOICE
VOTING FOR JURISDICTION FOLLOWS
MANY OF THE SAME PROTOCOLS AND
PROCEDURES THAT WERE CUSTOM TO
AN ELECTION ADMINISTRATION.
CONSIDER THAT YOU STILL HAVE
FILING YOU STILL HAVE A CERTAIN
DAY THAT YOU BURDEN THE VOTE
REPLACES OPEN.
TESTING AND PREPARATIONS ARE FOR
THE SAME.
JURISDICTIONS DO NOT HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL ANY LONGER
BECAUSE OF THE PRACTICES BY
OTHER JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE
THOSE PROCEDURES AND RESOURCES
IN PLACE.
I SAID THIS CAN ACTUALLY BE
APPLIED AT A LOCAL LEVEL OF A
VERY RULE LEVEL UP TO A VERY
URBAN AREA.
WITH GOOD INSTRUCTIONS WE KNOW
THE VOTERS DO YOU UNDERSTAND
VOTER EDUCATION CAN INVOLVE AS
LITTLE OR AS MUCH OF THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE PERMITTED.
SOME JURISDICTIONS HAVE DONE
EXTENSIVE CAMPAIGNS AND OTHERS
LIKE NORTH CAROLINA AND MAIN
HAVE BOTH HAD NO ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AT THE TIME WHEN THEY
WERE ASKED TO EXECUTE -- OR
CONDUCT A RIGHT CHOICE VOTING
ELECTION.
IDEALLY RCV EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH THAT'S CONSIDERED IN
THE BILL WOULD COMPLEMENT
EXISTING EDUCATIONAL EFFORTS AND
WE REALLY KNOW FROM PREVIOUS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MOST
IMPACTFUL AND INEXPENSIVE VOTER
EDUCATION METHOD.
IS VERBAL AND WRITTEN
INSTRUCTION WHEN THE VOTER
PRESENTS THEMSELVES TO VOTE --
LAST BUT NOT LEAST ALL SHARE
SOME DATA WITH YOU THE RECENT
ELECTIONS IN SANTA FE AND
MINNEAPOLIS THEY ARE ILLUSTRATE
THE VOTERS DO UNDERSTAND HAVE A
PROFICIENCY MARKING THERE ARE CD
BALLOTS.
IN MARCH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SANTA FE VOTERS USE RCV FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN ELECTING THE
CITY'S MAYOR AND IN TO CITY
COUNCIL RACES. 96% OF THE
BALLOTS THAT WERE CAST COUNT
COUNTED IN THE FINAL ROUND OF
THE MAY WORLD ALEXIAN AND JUST
ONE THIRD OF 1% HAD NO CAST VOTE
IN THE CONTEST. FOR MAYOR.
MINNEAPOLIS HAS NOW USE OUR CD
AND THREE ELECTION CYCLES AND
LOOKING AT THEIR DATA FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN ONLY ONE
FIFTH OF 1% OF BALLOTS.
HEAD OVER VOTE ERRORS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AND
SIMILARLY WITH THIRTY FIVE
MAYORAL CANDIDATES IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN THE ERROR
RATE WAS VERY MUCH THE SAME.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT LET US KNOW HOW WE
CAN BE OF ASSISTANCE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NO FURTHER WITNESSES WELL HERE
WE GO.
GATHERED FROM SANTA CRUZ AND I
AM A PASSIONATE SUPPORTER FRANK
CHOICE WRITING -- YOU JUST
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CITY WHEREVER I AM
THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR
OFTHANK OF A PEACE FREEDOM
FORTY CALIFORNIA AND WERE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ROSE THE
GOVERNMENT VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANKS.
PAUL THE LEAGUE CALIFORNIANS FOR
ELECTORAL REFORM THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN.
I'M BONNIE ELLEN FROM PETALUMA
AND I SUPPORT RANKED CHOICE
VOTING.
PATRICK LANG CALVET KLIEMAN
CAMPAIGN IS NOT YET TAKEN A
POSITION ON END IN SUPPORT BUT I
SUSPECT WE WILL I PERSONALLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GLORIA PUSH PURCELL FROM BELMONT
AND GREEN PARTY ALSO I PLEASE
LOVE THANK CHOICE VOTING.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S DAVID JACOBS I'M
WITH THE SECOND CHAPTER
REPRESENT US I URGE SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
YOU.
HI MY NAME.
MY NAME IS MIKE WILSON THIRD
DISTRICT SUPERVISOR FROM THE
COUNTY F HUMBOLDT.
ARE COUNTY -- ENDORSED THIS BILL --
SPECIFICALLY -- AS A RESPONSE TO
THE EXTENSION OF THE OF THE
PRIMARY SEASON TO MARCH WHICH IS
NOW MAKING AN ALMOST TWO YEAR
FIFTEEN ELECTORAL CYCLE -- FOR
FOR GENERAL LAW COUNTIES -- BUT
IN ALSO.
CREATES THE POTENTIAL OF TEN
MONTHS -- LAME DUCK INCUMBENCY
AS WELL -- WHICH IS ALSO UNFAIR
TO OUR VOTERS SO.
WE WOULD LIKE TO AT LEAST HAVE
THE OPTION TO DISCUSS A ONE AND
DONE OPTION IN TERMS OF HAVING
AN ELECTION IN NOVEMBER.
SO THAT WE CAN -- NOT HAVE THIS
PROBLEM THANKS.
THANK YOU UP OPPOSITION AND IN
UP OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATE.
OF BILLS BEEN MOVED.
OF ALL RIGHT MA'AM SECTOR IF
YOU'D OF SELLER BUT BROWN I JUST
WANT TO ECHO THAT WE DID WE DID
SOMETHING DRAMATIC IT WAS THERE
ARE SOME GOOD REASONS FOR A BY
MOVING THE PRIMARY FOR TO MARCH
WE REALLY HAVE.
AND SHUT UP THE SYSTEM A BIT IN
WAYS THAT I DON'T THINK WE FULLY
ANTICIPATED THIS IS ONE THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT WAY OF OF OF
INSURANCE WE DON'T HAVE.
LAME DUCK IN COMMENTS I WILL
POINT OUT THAT BOTH OF THE WOMEN
VOTERS ANALLY CALIFORNIA CITIES
OF COME ON AND ONE SUPPORT.
BECAUSE IT'S PERMISSIVE IT GIVES
TOOLS AND IT WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT WE WILL HAVE MORE COUNCILS
THAT TRULY REPRESENT THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE THE CENTER [inaudible]
MA'AM SECTOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
YOU BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENT.
YEAH.
HIS OWN MARK.
YOU KNOW.
THE PROPOSED.
ALL RIGHT -- SEN AROUND -- SB
SIX FORTY ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND I
FIRST WANT TO ACCEPT THE MEMBER
AS OUTLINED IN ANALYSIS.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL.
I THOSE OF US FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO ELSEWHERE IN
THE STATE KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
A PROLIFERATION OF SPECIAL
ELECTION STRUCK CALIFORNIA OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES.
AND THERE'S CURRENTLY A PRETTY
SHORT WINDOW OF ONLY A FEW WEEKS
IN WHICH SPECIAL ACTIONS CAN
OCCUR.
OUR CURRENT LAW DOES PERMIT
COUNTIES TO CONSOLIDATE A
SPECIAL ACTION WITH THE
REGULARLY SCHEDULED STATEWIDE
ELECTION WERE LOCAL ELECTION
WITHIN A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OF
THE VACANCY.
THIS BILL AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED WILL EXTEND THE THAT
CONSOLIDATION TIMELINE TO TUTOR
DAYS.
AND ALSO A LOT OF CONSOLIDATION
WITH ANY.
OUR ELECTION WITH YOUR WITH ANY
ELECTION OCCURRING WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION -- A PORTLY THIS
CHANGE GIVES THE GOVERNOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO WORK LOCAL
COUNTIES TO DETERMINE THE BEST
ELECTION DAY FOR SPECIAL ACTIONS.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IN THE END OF
THE DAY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF.
THERE IS A AN EXISTING PECIAL
EXISTING REGULAR ELECTION OR
SPECIAL ACTION IT'S ALREADY
HAPPENING IN SOMEWHERE IN THE
DISTRICT.
THAT -- WITH AS MANY VACANCY.
INSTEAD OF HAVING YOU KNOW ONE
ELECTION ONE WEEK IN ANOTHER
ELECTION THE NEXT WEEK WE
ALREADY HAVE SUCH PROBLEMS WITH
TURN OUT.
LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GIVE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LOCALS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CONSOLIDATE -- WE HAD A
SITUATION IN LOS ANGELES WHERE
WE WERE HAVING A SPECIAL
ELECTION EVERY FOUR WEEKS IN THE
SAME AREA ONE FOR THE SCHOOL
BOARD IN THE CITY COUNCIL AND
THERE WAS A ASSEMBLY.
A NINE AND THE CAN THE CONGRESS
AND IT WAS JUST A A CRAZY MIX OF
ELECTIONS HAPPENING -- BEING A
MONTH AFTER MONTH AND IF WE'D
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SOME
MORE CONSOLIDATION.
IT COULD HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
COME IN AND VOTE TOGETHER VOTE
ALL ONE DOLLAR AND HAVE A JUST A
SIMPLER SYSTEM IT WOULD BE LESS
COSTLY AND LESS.
LESS LESS HECTIC AMID VOTERS
WERE JUST LIVE IT WITH YOU KNOW
THEY WANT TO BE GOOD RESPONSIBLE
CITIZENS BUT IT WAS CRAZY HOW
MANY TIMES THEY WERE BEING ASKED
TO VOTE.
IN THE SAME AREA -- FOR
DIFFERENT ELECTION SO THIS HELPS
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IF IT
GIVES FLEXIBILITY DOESN'T
REQUIRE -- BUT ALLOWS THE
GOVERNOR TO TALK WITH THE LOCALS
AND FIGURE OUT THE BEST PATH
MOVING FORWARD WE DO HAVE
AGENCIES.
AND WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THIS IS A SPORT.
OPPOSITION OF BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
DID YOU EVER ON THE ILLICIT
COMMITTEE CHAIR THE THREE PARTY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT WE SENT A
BILL OR WE SEND INFORMATION IN
BUT I GUESS SOMEHOW GOT LOST IN
THE SYSTEM.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL LOOK
[inaudible]
FOR THE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED --
SEN AROUND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
IDEA X. LADY IT'S GREAT TIME
SAVER AS WELL AS A MONEY SAVER
SO THANK YOU.
OKAY -- WE WE ARE ARE LACKING
SOME MEMBERS BUT MADAM SECRETARY
IF.
YOU ARE CLOSE YEAH I KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO HAVE
A SUPPORT LEGAL AND VOTERS IN A
NUMBER OF THE GROUPS AND IT'S A
SMALL BELL BUT I I DO THINK IT
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN IN IN
IN THE INCIDENTS WHERE.
WHERE WE'VE SEEN THIS KIND OF --
WASTE BY TEN SO AT WITHOUT I
RESPECT RESTAURANT ABOUT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ABSURDITY CULTURAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG.
LEYVA.
STERN.
BILLS ON CALL.
THANK YOU MAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
ALLOWING ME TO CUT INTO YOUR
PRESENTATION MISTER CHAIR.
AT THE TO DO SO WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE HERE TO PLEASE THEIR OWN.
BUT RIGHTS COME BACK AND SEE US
SO.
RIGHT.
IF THERE'S NO ONE ELSE I THINK I
WILL --
SIX SENATOR UMBERG
THIS'LL BE.
SIX NINE SIX WELL.
FOR TWO THREE FIVE FOUR TWO
THREE SB FORTY THREE THANK YOU
I'M CENTER NIELSEN -- SB EVIL
FOR TWENTY THREE IS A SIMPLE
BILL -- HAS TWO COMPONENTS TO IT
IS IT'S SPONSORED BY THE F. PPC --
IN ONE COMPONENT.
REQUIRES THAT THAT BASICALLY OF
ONE ACCOUNT FOR ONE PURPOSE THE
OTHER PART.
ALLOW SHOULD REDACT CERTAIN
PERSONAL INFORMATION WHEN THE
FORM IS FILE WHEN YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE A CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
IN OTHER FORMS ARE FILED -- WITH
ME HERE IS MISTER FURLONG FROM
THEIR PPC.
WE ALSO HAVE A SECTOR STATES
OFFICER WITH A WELL.
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU SIR
NIELSEN FILL UP ON A BEHALF OF
THE I. P. P. C. WE ARE SPONSORS
OF THIS BUT I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ON BOTH FOR AUTHORING --
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THAT -- THE
DESERT THE EXCITING TOPIC OF
BANK ACCOUNTS FOR CAMPAIGNS --
THE CAMPAIGNS -- RIGHT NOW I'M
ONLY CANDY COMMITTEES ARE --
REQUIRED TO CREATE THANK
ACCOUNTS TO SEGREGATE THEIR
ACCOUNTS FROM -- AND NON
CAMPAIGN -- FUNDS -- THE WE WE
HAVE HIGHLY RECOMMENDED THAT ALL
OTHER COMMITTEES DO SO FOR MANY
MANY YEARS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES THEIR
CAMPAIGN ACCOUNTS BE SEPARATE --
FROM NON CAMPAIGN FUNDS AND SO
IT IS FOR THE MOST PART A BEST
PRACTICE IN THE INDUSTRY -- AND
IN THOUGH AND AND IN OUR FIELD
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE BOUGHT THAT BREAKS.
THAT BEST PRACTICE HERE -- TO
CALIFORNIA -- THE SECOND PART OF
THE BILL -- DEALS WITH REDUCTION
OF BANK ACCOUNT NUMBERS --
OBVIOUSLY HAVING A BANK ACCOUNT
NUMBER IS -- IS IMPORTANT TO
BANKING -- AND BUT PROTECTING IT
FROM PUBLIC CONSUMPTION IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO PREVENT A POTENTIAL
ABUSE AND FRAUD FROM -- EVIL
DOERS OUT THERE WHO WHO MAY WISH --
TO TAKE FUNDS OR OR TEND TO
WRITE BAD OR FAKE CHECKS FROM
I'M CAMPAIGN COMMITTEES -- WHO
YOU'RE CHEN PURPOSE COMMITTEES
ARE PRIMARILY FORM COMMITTEE
SINCE -- OR EVEN CAN'T A
COMMITTEES AND SO WE ARE -- THEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
THE SPONSORS AND WE HOPE TO HAVE
YOUR I FELT THANK YOU.
IF YOU MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
THE BILL HELPS PROVIDE PRIVACY
FOR BANK ACCOUNT NUMBERS -- FOR
THOSE REASONS WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
OTHERS WE HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
I DON'T THINK SO OKAY ANYONE IN
A FAR OPPOSITION [inaudible]
NUMBER OPPOSITION [inaudible]
AND THE ISSUE THE THIS CHAIRMAN
THE ONE BANK ACCOUNT RULE -- THE
SOUND IT WOULD IT'S MANAGE
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
THERE'S SOME CONFLICT WHAT WOULD
BE THAT CONFLICT IN THAT WOULD
BE ADDRESSES.
I'M I'M NOT AWARE THE CONFLICT
ON ESTá STRONG TO RESPOND TO
THAT.
I THINK THIS IS THAT YOU ARE YOU
SPEAKING ABOUT.
OF COURSE ANALYSIS YES CORY --
YES -- THE THE ISSUE THAT I'M
HAS RECENTLY ARISEN -- IS THE
ONE BANK ACCOUNT ROLE DOESN'T
NECESSARY WORK FOR POLITICAL
PARTIES WHO MUST HAVE ALL
PURPOSE ACCOUNTS AND RESTRICTED
USE ACCOUNTS -- SO IF YOU'RE
POLITICAL PARTY AND YOUR PLAN ON
SPENDING MONEY ON STATE
CANDIDATES WHO ARE SUBJECT TO
LIMIT.
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS --
INDIVIDUALS CAN ONLY GIVE UP TO
A CERTAIN AMOUNT TO THAT
POLITICAL PARTY FOR THAT PURPOSE
OF SUPPORTERS THE CANDIDATES --
ANY OTHER AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER ACCOUNT THE RESTRICTED
ACCOUNT WHICH POLITICAL PARTIES
CAN USE FOR ANY PURPOSE AND
THERE'S NO LIMITS ON THEM -- AND
SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
ATTORNEYS -- FOR THE POLITICAL
PARTIES TO TRY TO REMEDY THAT
ISSUE IT'S NOT A HUGE CONFLICT.
THE SMALL LITTLE MINISTRY TO
THING THAT WE THINK -- WE HAVE
FOUND A SOLUTION TO WE JUST NEED
TO PROPOSE IT TO OUR COMMISSION
AND AND AND HAVE THEM APPROVED
AT THE LANGUAGES -- IT'S GOOD TO
GO THAT THE TWO MAJOR PARTIES IN
YOUR TO DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM OF
CONCURRED OR REACH SOME
AGREEMENT HERE THEN I BELIEVE SO
YEAH.
A GOOD ALL RIGHT.
AND WE HAVE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
AND THERE'D BE NO -- COMMITTEE
REALLY HERE TO SPEAK OF IT MAY
BUT IF YOU LIKE TO CHANGE -- AND
WILL MAKE A MOTION FOR THE PAST
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSER THANK YOU ORIGINAL VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE
HERTZBERG.
LEYVA STERN [inaudible]
SOURCE
. FOR THOSE OF YOU ARE
SELECTIONS HAVE.
ONLY TWO MORE BILLS CENTER STERN
I'M INFORMED IS PRESENTING A
BILL RIGHT NOW I'M SORRY ONE
MORE BILL -- JUST -- I REMEMBER
SEVEN SB
[inaudible]
SIX THIRTY SIX HI
YEAH.
THE SERVER HERTZBERG WE'RE IN
LOVE CALLS ON ALL THE BILLS --
WE HAVE ONE BUILT YET. FOR
PRESENTATION CORRECT CENTER
STERN -- SO.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU'D.
CALL THE BILLS IN ORDER.
SB TWO ONE TWO ALLEN MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE AS TO WHY IS ONE KNOW WHAT
THE CHAIR VOTING I HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NUYS LEVEL.
I AM TO SB THREE HUNDRED AMBERG.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CAR VOTERS THREE
EYES NO NOSE.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE.
ITEM THREE SB THREE FIFTY NINE
WARLOCK MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CAR VOTE
IS THREE EYES NO NOSE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
I ITEM FOUR S. BEFORE ONE BATES
MOTION IS TO PASS TO SEND
APPROVED APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE KNOWS AND
NO I IS HERTZBERG.
I AM FIVE SB FOUR TWENTY THREE
NUMBER MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CRIME VOTE
IS TWO EYES NO NOSE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI.
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI.
ITEM SIX SP FOUR THIRTY ONE
MCGUIRE.
MOTION IS TO PASS CURRENT LOTUS
TWO EYES AND ONE KNOW WHAT THE
CHAIR VOTING I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I I DON'T KNOW ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB SIX FORTY ONE
ALLEN MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
CAR VOTE IS TO EYES AND NO ONE
KNOWS WHAT THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG FINE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE IS SB SIX
NINETY SIX NUMBER WHICH IS A
CONSENT ITEM.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I ALL RIGHT.
SINCE YOU CAN GO TO A SCHOOL
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
AND SEVEN COMMITTEE CHAIR ENGINE
TEN SECONDS.
THERE STERN AYE SINCERE
APOLOGIES MYSTERY HERE THOUGH I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE DOING
OTHER LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS SO SB.
SIX THIRTY SIX VERY GOOD --
NUMBER.
SEVEN YES SO.
I'M PLEASE RESENT YOU SB SIX
THIRTY SIX THE BALLOT DISCLOSE
ACT -- AND FIRST I WANT TO START
OFF BY THANKING.
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR NOW SAYS
AND THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO
ALLOW -- SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION TO
REALLY TRY TO MAKE THIS WORK --
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THEM. FOR MANY
VOTERS ARE ARE BALANCER.
COMPLETELY ON INTERPRETABLE AND
EVEN AFTER YOU'VE DONE YOUR
DILIGENCE SAY BY REVIEWING%
EDITORIALS OR DOING YOUR HOME
AND HOMEWORK IN THE BALLOT GUIDE
YOU FINALLY ARRIVE AT THAT
SEMINAL MOMENT WHERE YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE.
TO CHECK THE BOX OR STAMP THE
THE THE OR IN IN IN NEW CASES A
TOUCH THE SCREEN.
AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHO ACTUALLY
IS BEHIND -- THE MEASURE YOUR
VOTING ON SO WE THINK THAT THIS
MEASURE FEELS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT GAP BY GIVING VOTERS
MEANINGFUL INFORMATION ACTUALLY
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT THE
ENDORSERS SUPPORTERS OF THE
BALLOT MEASURE THEIR VOTING ON
TO MAKE THESE ELECTIONS.
AND THE VOTING PROCESS MUCH MORE
ACCESSIBLE -- SO WE WOULD BE
MODIFYING THE BALLOT MEASURE
LABELS WITH THIS MEASURE -- TO
INCLUDE THE OFFICIAL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF BALLOT MEASURES
HOW WE THINK THAT PUTTING THIS
OFFICIAL SUPPORT IN A WAY THAT.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY -- NOW WITH
THE AMENDMENTS BIAS IT JUST
TOWARDS ORGANIZATIONAL SUPPORT --
BUT WITH A SORT OF FLEXIBLE WORD
LIMIT BASED SYSTEM TO OCCUPY A
MINIMAL AMOUNT OF SPACE WITH
MAXIMUM IMPACT FOR DISCLOSURE --
ON AVERAGE A LISTING THREE
SUPPORTERS AND THREE OPPONENTS
WILL ACTUALLY ONLY HAD ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE WORDS TO EACH
SEVENTY FIVE WORD BALLOT LABEL
FOR STATE BALLOT MEASURES -- SO
WE DON'T THINK THE INCREASE IN
LENGTH IS GOING TO BE --
EXCESSIVE -- AND THAT POWER THAT
KNOWLEDGE IS IS WORTH -- THAT
THAT SMALL INCREMENTAL --
EDITION -- TO OUR BALLOT TO
FULFILL WHAT WE FEEL IS A
CITIZENS MOST SACRED OBLIGATION
WHICH IS NOT JUST TO BE A VOTER
BUT TO BE AN INFORMED VOTER --
AND SO -- WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND INTRODUCE OUR SPONSORS
LEGISLATION -- TRAVELING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN -- ALONG WITH -- EVAN
MENTOR WITH THAT QUALITY
CALIFORNIA MY RIGHT NOW SORRY.
ALL RIGHT I WITHOUT WITH FOR
VOICE ABOUT ROBBERS GOT IT.
MY MY APOLOGIES.
THE THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING AND
CHAIR OF THE SENATORS -- REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER STERN
STEPPING FORWARD TO LEAD ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL THE AS AS HE
DESCRIBED AS NOTHING MORE --
MEANINGFUL THAN WITH THE VOTES
THAT PEOPLE TAKE ON THE BALLOT
THAT THE CURRENTLY IT WITH IT
HAS A SEVENTY FIVE WORD VERY
CONDENSED -- TITLE AND SUMMARY
OF THE MUCH LONGER -- SUMMARY
AND FISCAL IMPACT STATEMENTS
IT'S VERY CONFUSING TO VOTERS --
IN THE HOT I HAVE EVEN HAD A
INITIATIVES THAT WE SUPPORT
WHERE YOU LOOK AT THE TWO
SENTENCES THAT THEY CRAM IN THE
CONDENSER MARIE.
AND ONE I'M SURE THAT I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT IT
BASED OFF OF ONLY THOSE TWO
SENTENCES SO KNOWING WHO THE
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS ARE --
THAT SIGNED THE OFFICIAL BALLOT
PAMPHLET STATEMENTS WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL WE THINK THAT WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT THAT WE'RE
ACCEPTING THAT WILL ALLOW THE
PROPONENTS OF AN OPPONENT'S THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DESCRIBE IN THE
MOST INFORMATIVE WAY POSSIBLE.
WHILE.
LIMITING IT TO ONLY FIFTEEN
WORDS IN EACH CASE SO -- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THE THE AMENDMENTS
ACT ACTUALLY ARE PROPOSED FOR
LATER INCLUSION THE NOT INCLUDED
TODAY NOT THE BILL TODAY SO
SOMETIME BETWEEN.
NOW THEM IN THE NEXT STEP
CORRECT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I AM EVAN MAINTAIN I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA VOICES FOR PROGRESS
I'M ALSO THAT CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND CHAIR OF
THE LGBT CAUCUS BUT I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF VOICES FOR PROGRESS
TODAY.
AND LEASES FOR PROGRESS
GALVANIZES THE ADVOCACY OF
BUSINESS LEADERS ENTREPRENEURS
INVESTORS FOR ENTERPRISE AND
OTHER PROMINENT INDIVIDUALS TO
PROTECT OUR CLIMATE.
STRENGTH IN OUR DEMOCRACY AND AB.
ENSURE ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
AND WE VIEW THIS BILL AS AN EASY
AN IMPORTANT BALLOT TRANSPARENCY
AND BETTER EDUCATION MAJOR.
IT'S PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN
THIS DAY AND AGE THAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN NOW.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THE
BALLOT GUIDES ARE OFTEN
CUMBERSOME AND CROSS COMPARING
INFORMATION FROM THE BALLOT
GUIDE. TO THE DEAD VOTER AB.
BALLET IS A BIRD IS IN PROCESS
FOR THE VOTER.
AND AND I'M SORRY I WISH THAT I
HAD MY COFFEE AND IS BURDENSOME
PROCESS FOR THE VOTER.
AND THAT IS IT FOR VOTER EVEN
KNOWS -- REALIZES THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE SAVED THE PAMPHLET.
AND HAVING THIS INFORMATION ON
THE BALLOT ITSELF WILL BE
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL INFORMATION
RIGHT AT THE VOTERS FINGER TAPS.
UNTIL WE CAN GET MONEY OUT OF
POLITICS WE URGE YOU TO DO THE
NEXT BEST THING AND THAT IS
PROVIDING TRANSPARENCY AND THAT
MEANS FULL TRANSPARENCY AS THIS
BILL DOES. TO THE VOTER AND WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
THANK SERVE -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WAS THERE A MARROW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
DID YOU EVER AS AN INDIVIDUAL I
IN SUPPORT.
YOU.
MY BODY ALLEN FROM PETALUMA AND
I SUPPORT SB.
SIX THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
ENCINA FROM PALO ALTO IN SUPPORT.
ALLEN MARLING FROM ALAMEDA IN
SUPPORT.
SURELY SHELLING DUSKY PLEASANT
HILL IN SUPPORT -- DAN BERMAN
DAVIS CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT SB.
SIX THIRTY SIX AND THE BOSTON
RED SOX.
DAVID JACOBS LOCAL CHAPTER OF
SACRAMENTO REPRESENT U ON THE
PHONE SUPPORT PLEASE.
GLORIA PURCELL BELMONT PLEASE
SUPPORT.
GENERAL IN RAN PALO ALTO.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CHRISTOPHER LESS FROM SANDRA
FELL IN SUPPORT.
MARY KILL STANFORD IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER HAITI SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS.
PATCH WHEN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT WITH AMENDMENTS.
MULLIN THE CRIED SACRAMENTO I
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
RALPH PHILLY SAN JOSE THREE
FIFTY DOT ORG ALSO.
THEY GIVE ME ALLOW VERA SAN JOSE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OF THERE WE GO THE GENERAL
LUNDGREN'S AGO WE ALL TRAFFIC
JAM THERE.
MA'AM -- ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD.
SEVERAL LANGAN FROM MOUNTAIN
VIEW AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ASK FOR YOUR YES VOTE THANK YOU.
JERRY HOW MUCH SACRAMENTO
SUPPORT.
MARY RYAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TERRY MORE OF ITS FROM MILL
VALLEY.
MAKE THIS EASY.
WOMEN WHERE TO FROM NEVADA I
SUPPORT THIS BILL PLEASE SUPPORT
MAKE IT EASIER FOR VOTERS THANK
YOU.
DAVID NEWSLETTER SUNNYVALE
SUPPORT.
I'LL HANDLE TAXI FROM SAN JOSE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALL RIGHT A COMB SEGMENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KIM.
KIM SELLIN FROM DAVE'S
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN LOVE CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE ACTIONS FUNDING IN
SUPPORT.
BRED FROM SANTA CRUZ I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JACQUELYN DOOR SACRAMENTO I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAROL TIPPING FROM SAN JOSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ALLEN BRINKER SUNNYVALE IN
SUPPORT AND I'D LIKE TO BRING
OUT A POINT.
WE CANNOT YOU CAN OR VOTERS
ENOUGH.
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE
WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE A
COMPUTER SCREEN WORLD A VOTE AND
THEY CAN PUT WHATEVER
INFORMATION THEY WANT NâNG.
MENUS ACROSS FILE WHATEVER BUT I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK IN
THAT DIRECTION.
AND I THINK THIS IS A STEP THAT
WAY RIGHT NOW IT'S ALL ON PAPER.
IN THE NOT TOO DISTANT FUTURE
IT'S GOING TO BE ELECTRONIC.
AND I THINK THIS IS WHERE MOVES
TO EDUCATE.
THANK YOU SIR.
HOW DO I JONES FROM SAN JOSE
HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU?
STAY BURKE FOR METAL I SUPPORT
TO THANK YOU.
CRAIG DUNKERLEY US AND AS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR -- OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
AND IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT -- WILL BRING BACK
COMMITTEE -- QUESTIONS THAT ARE
HERTZBERG -- WILL -- SO SENATOR
STERN -- I I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US -- I
CONCUR WITH THIS STATEMENTS WITH
CONCERNING INFORMATION BEING
BOTH IMPORTANT -- AND ACCESSIBLE
IS THE CHALLENGE WE FACE IS MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T PROVIDE TOO
MUCH INFORMATION WE DON'T.
CREATE ABOUT THIS TOO LONG SO
THAT WE HAVE.
THE OTER FATIGUE -- BUT I
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ENSURE THAT WE
STRIKE THE PERFECT BALANCE SO.
HAVING SAID THAT -- THE BILLS
WOULD MOVEMENT SECTOR IF YOU
CALL THE ROLL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ALL YES
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE EXCELLENT
LAWYER WHEN MAKING A TRIP IN.
FOR IT IS S. FLEXING THE POWER
DEMOCRACY IN THEIR OWN HANDS
TRULY DO APPRECIATE IT YES GOOD
POINT.
BUT HE FOR SHOWING UP IMPORTANT
VISUAL IMPORTANT WE'LL GET THIS
BILL OUT.
WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT
WAIT WAIT WAIT.
THAT YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO
JINX IT SO JUST JUST LET YOU
KNOW THAT.
THAT WAS A LITTLE THAT WAS A
LITTLE PRESUMPTUOUS SO.
ALL RIGHT RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT
HERE WE GO.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
I AM VERY [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE IT
LEYVA STERN STERN HI.
ALL RIGHT THE THE BILL THE BILL
IS OUT -- I THINK -- CENTER
HERTZBERG GET YOUR WE WE'VE OPEN
THE ROLE YOU'RE ON EVERYTHING
RIGHT.
YES SENATOR STERN.
CENTER LEYVA.
IN CENTER NIELSEN -- WE'RE GONNA
OF OPEN THE ROLE AGAIN THAT WAS
THE LAST BILL WE'RE GONNA OPEN
THE ROLE AGAIN HERE.
MOMENTARILY [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WELL.
YOU KNOW WHAT ALL IT ALL IT'S
SINISTER LITTLE AS WELL.
ALWAYS WELCOME BACK ALL RIGHT
THEN LET'S LET'S GO AHEAD AND
CENTER LEYVA -- WILL WE WILL
WE'LL KEEP OPEN AGAIN.
FOR ALL RIGHT -- BOB SUBJECT
CALL THE ROLL ON THE BILLS ARE
ON CALL AND THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN --
WITH RULES BEEN HELD OPEN.
SB TWO ONE TWO ALLEN MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI STERN.
SB THREE HUNDRED NUMBER DO
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
STERN.
STERN FINE.
SB THREE FIFTY NINE MORE LOCKS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS STERN.
THE THREE FIFTY NINE YES I STERN
HI.
SB FOUR ONE BATES MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
STERN.
NO STERN NO.
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE NUMBER TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
LEYVA.
STERN STERN TIME.
SB FOUR THIRTY ONE MCGUIRE TO
PASS STERN [inaudible]
STERN HI [inaudible]
SB.
SB SIX FORTY ONE ALLEN.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SEND
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA STERN.
STERN ONLINE SB -- SIX NINETY
SIX HEARD CONSENT ITEMS STERN
[inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH.
BUT I THINK THAT'S RIGHT ALL
RIGHT.
OKAY SB FOUR TWENTY THREE NUMBER.
LEYVA.
FIVE SB SIX THIRTY SIX STERN.
I DO PATTERSON APPROPRIATIONS
LABOR.
LEYVA HI.
AND SB SIX FORTY ONE ALLEN LEYVA.
LEYVA.
RIGHT I THINK THAT -- WE ARE
ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU ALL [inaudible]
YEAH